hi there hello Janet who's that man this
is my new rebound boyfriend Derek I made
him hi I'm Derek you must be Mike oh
okay that makes more sense you must be
Michael
Janet's made a lot of talk talking in my
ear holes about you Michael Michael
Michael Michael Michael Michael Janet
you can't make a person I know but I did
though Eleanor said that to forget about
Jason
I should create a rebound guy so I made
one Derek my boyfriend and she made me
he's so nice
whoa look at this glass oh my god I'm in
there too what's going on right now it's
my first time making someone so he might
be a little bit off look this could be
done please put that down this could be
very dangerous it shouldn't even be
possible
well maybe not 800 reboots ago but
apparently now it is Derek is it Derek
it's Derek Derek could you please give
me and Janet a moment alone go back to
the void babe I'll be there in a minute
okay let me see you look crazy I miss
you more no I'll miss you more bye what
a dork
am i right some of you just met
detective pimento and of course some of
you knew him before he went undercover
Hitchcock and Scully you guys still work
here the only way they're getting rid of
us is in a body bag it actually happened
once but it was a false alarm
detective pimento will be returning to
his old desk Peralta will temporarily be
moved to the break room questions what
you do undercover I worked for Jimmy the
butcher Figgis that is an a-list mobster
tell me literally everything everyone
shut up pretty much just a bagman for
him I mean I did some other stuff
[Laughter]
um we usually try to tell funnier little
stories well there's nothing funny about
what I did for the butcher I've had to
learn not to blink because every time I
close my eyes I see a fresh or ooh dark
how do you keep your eyes moist now
actually I have a very funny story about
keeping my eyes moist I'm gonna cut
right to the chase
I don't like charity I don't get it
feels to me like I'm giving money away
and getting nothing in return well
that's not true you can really help your
personal brand if you show that you're a
mogul that gives as much as he gets if I
give as much as I get I'm giving 20
million dollars oh yeah yeah that's how
much I'm worth 20 million dollars yeah
uh he's disgusting but I want to take
his money and give it to needy people so
I'm just gonna keep on smiling people
who give to charity they get amazing
press like Bill Gates have you ever
heard of Bill Gates he lives in Seattle
guy with glasses
Bill Gates I know who Bill Gates is Bill
Gates is like a super nerd is this some
sort of nerd thing are you calling me a
nerd he meant Mark Cuban Cuban now
that's the kind of guy I can hang out
with Mark Cuban yeah I'm interested now
keep talking a lot of charities waste
their money on overhead but we at the
sweetums foundation spend our money
wisely okay you know what shut up all
right you guys seem like pretty cool
dudes and I'm feeling pretty generous so
why don't we take this conversation to
the Pawnee smokehouse dumb-dumb Eddie
get the checkbook we're going out whoa
guys we're going out let's sent up I
call dibs on news
I got money shot yeah I got blood spurt
oh no don't use that one hey go ahead
too hard to explain
I'll show you Janet hi there hey there
who the fork is that Derek Hostetler p.i
Derek is my rebound guy I made him oh
did you do that because uh
of what I said yes because of what you
said Janet thank you Eleanor
thank you Eleanor you know you seem so
sad want me to make you a boyfriend too
well I could have a brother yes based on
your last 10,000 comments it would be
Stone Cold Steve Austin's head on to
honey's body or vice versa she's not
gonna make you anything
Janet that'll be all okay goodbye say
goodbye Derek uh good Bob I hope we same
place again very now his brain is wrong
this is my desk okay okay well now that
that's out of the way I was just coming
to let you know we're gonna work a B&E
together we're gonna be partners
nope I work alone plus the butcher says
he has spies in the NYPD so I trust none
of these dildos listen you can trust me
I'm like obsessed with you right fine
tell me something you've never told
another living soul ooh here's one
I'm actually not strong enough to lift a
water-cooler jug so I always find a way
to make Terry do it here's mine
Jimmy the butcher made me drive a
croquet wicket through a guy's eyes into
his brain brain leaked out his eyes like
he was crying his own mind my goodness
now that I've heard yours I feel like my
water cooler thing could hold more
juicing but no that was embarrassing for
you
a bond has been made
feels good to trust again brother Wow
either you are a cyborg or you're
carrying so many weapons in this jacket
you know they claim that smoking is bad
for you but is there any medical
evidence to back that up great point
so the sweetums Foundation has really
accomplished a lot recently our
healthcare outreach program has reduced
a pink eye in the rural community by 30
percent to 70 percent snooze you guys
ever been fox hunting I have my own
foxes flown in from Russia we drug them
pretty heavily so they can't get very
far in fact mostly they just flop around
on the ground makes it easier to just
walk up and bow stupid foxes it's deeply
erotic that sounds amazing we should go
hunting sometime I'd love to I can bust
out my Ralph Lauren fall 2010 collection
captain in 2012
clearance rack wear whatever you want
as long as it's not too bright or
reflective you know I want you blending
in to the surroundings how fast can you
run I think that guy wants to haunt me
let's do Dennis not to interrupt then
don't shut him right down I have heard
so much talking from you I don't want to
hear your fat mouth say anything you're
a dick
excuse me Andy how dare you talk to me
like that where are you manners
you come to me asking for money and you
treat me like this
I don't think so wrap it up we're done
hey show these garbage people out take
the garbage out Eddie Donna gentlemen
bad janet walkie-talkie mode now
entering mindy st. Claire's house this
is so exciting I hope everyone gets hurt
living room is clear entering the
bedroom are you guys friends hi I'm
Derek where are the humans and who is
Derek me is Derek these are my wind
chimes Oh Oh my wind chimes like you the
only people here at Mindy st. Claire and
an unknown male with the genital
deformity the four humans are not here
Papa's here oh so scared there's a place
for my claws oh honey she's okay I'm
here
monsters aren't real my little pierogi
but I saw it was big and hairy you just
had a nightmare buddy no it was real
sure it felt that way but I I'm gonna
open this closet and I'm gonna show you
that there's nothing in there don't do
that blah blah see nothing
hey Chuck its Plymouth well well well
look who's back thank you so much for
seeing us again sir
we just came to apologize mr. Dennis
fine Steve let me just say from the
bottom of my heart my bad I just started
working here and I really wanted to do a
good job and I blew it
thank you for saying that thought about
it last night and I decided that if you
came in here and apologized to me like a
man that I would forgive you and that's
what you've done
so you're forgiven to that end here is a
check for $25,000 for your charity go
out there and help some kids with their
pinkeye or whatever it is you guys are
doing mr. Feinstein thank you this is
extremely generous it's nothing really
I'm happy to help this check is made out
to go yourself in your face Dennis
Feinstein helps no man get the hell out
of my office what's your problem hold on
a sec okay mr. Feinstein with all due
respect you are a major dick what who
are you Derek thanks for helping us all
those times we showed up to repay you
here's a willing sex robot in two duffel
bags full of cocaine there are wind
chimes where my ding dong should be I
can work with that
you